welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Ironman launched the decade of
joy that we now know as the infinity
saga years later the films still feels
like it came out yesterday because it's
DNA ran through every MCU film to the
present day even the MCU films of
tomorrow hopefully hope is the name of
the game here at new rock stars as we
spend this quarantine period with an
in-depth rewatch and breakdown of every
infinity saga film and if I look or
sound different it's because the blue
dungeon has been temporarily relocated
to a bunker even closer to the Earth's
core but the limited air supply isn't
stopping me for breaking down Iron Man's
scene-by-scene for all the fascinating
visual secrets that we overlooked an
earlier reviews let's get started the
film opens with a cdc's back in black
[Music]
this of course becomes Iron Man's kind
of anthem happy Hogan calls it back when
Peter Parker emulates Tony Stark and far
from home Tony Stark Robert Downey jr.
sells arms at Afghanistan with director
Jon Favreau updating Tony's wartime
origin story from Vietnam in the comics
to modern times
Tony poses for selfies I don't want to
see the Sun in my space [ __ ] please no
gang signs no throw it up I'm kidding
yeah Tony's a version of social media
comes back again in the theory if you
find this recording don't post it on
social media it's gonna be a real
tearjerker but really Tony's take on
peace is the key to his character he
begins his journey as a peace hating war
monger but right after his escape and
transformation he flashes a peace sign
and that goal of peace comes back again
and again in the saga
peace in our time I just want peace
Tony's funby gets hit and he's kidnapped
by terrorists and right away you can see
from their red banner that this is the
ten rings a shadowy Network controlled
we learned by the Mandarin originally
the Mandarin was going to be Iron Man's
primary villain in this first movie but
Favreau held off realizing that like the
Emperor and star wars audiences tend to
be more accepting of magical masterminds
from the shadows when he's introduced
later in the sequels now we did get a
version of the Mandarin an Iron Man 3
but Marvel has hinted that the real
Mandarin is still out there and he
we'll finally be revealed in the
upcoming Shanxi in the legend of the ten
rings played by Tony Leung an award
ceremony we meet rody played in this
movie by Terrence Howard now Howard was
set up to play war machine in the sequel
next time but due to contract disputes
over his pay he did not return and was
replaced by Don Cheadle and notice the
music here this theme comes back
throughout the bill
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they're all renditions the 60s Ironman
animated series theme in except Tony's
behalf is Jeff Bridges as Obadiah Stane
well I'm not Tony Stark cleans and
beaver Tony defines his character later
these exact words of what finally
trigger Obie into action well I'm sorry
I'm not Tony Stark
oh he plays this interesting song on
Tony's piano later how'd it go with that
bad huh this is actually a composition
by Antonio Salieri the envious colleague
of the genius Mozart Salieri was rumored
to have plotted to kill Mozart don't
that's disputed but really as the
Salieri to Tony's Mozart ubi will never
be Stark only stop I ain't stayin
Favreau himself plays Tony's bodyguard
happy Hogan whose role is expanded in
later films an Tony runs in a Vanity
Fair reporter Christine Everhart now the
comics Christine Everhart works for the
Daily Bugle later in the MCU she
continues on as an anchor for whi H and
at Tony's home she hears the voice of
Tony's OS future vision Paul Bettany as
Jarvis just a rather very intelligent
system Tony named it after Edwin Jarvis
Howard Starks Butler who was played by
James D'Arcy and agent Carter and made a
cameo in Avengers endgame we also meet
Gwyneth Paltrow as Pepper Potts politely
taking out the trash and as always be me
Tony on schedule MIT commencement in
June please don't harangue me brows
tough Tony shrugs off speaking at his
alma mater MIT but later in the series
when he cares more about his
responsibility to society in civil war
he finally speaks at MIT Tony tinkers
with his Ford Roadster which kind of
serves as an analogue for his new armor
like notice how the look of his original
art reactor reflects the valves of the
exposed roadster engine and later the
roadster serves as an inspiration for
the color scheme of the Hartmann tell
you would throw a little hotrod red in
there on the plane we see the stark
family crest a double-headed eagle which
is historically an imperial sigil for an
empire fighting wars on all fronts
never at peace just like how Tony begins
his journey and then the music video
that plays is Ghostface Killah as we
celebrate Ghostface Killah is a huge fan
of the Iron Man character and was gonna
cameo in this movie has a Dubai tycoon
but the scene was removed and then Tony
presents his Jericho missile the first
missile system to incorporate our
proprietary repulsor technology and he's
already dropping the word repulsor in
there to establish how he derived the
Iron Man repulsor blasts Tech from his
missile hardware and then we're back in
the cave Tony meets Jensen Jensen is
also from the comics when Tony's origin
was in Vietnam he rants and mentions
having met Tony at a tech conference in
Bern which Iron Man 3 will later show in
its prologue this tin ring cell is
headed up by Raza now Raza is also from
the Marvel Comics but he's a Shiar
cyborg pirate but in this movie when
whereas his face is burned it makes me
look a bit like his kind of self but
still primarily here he's part of the
mandarins Network and you'll notice that
any time he talks about his ambitions
there's a real eastward focus but
allowed the great Genghis Khan the rule
from the Pacific the Ukraine a man with
a dozen of things can rule all of Asia
Raza also wears this ring which summit
theorized could be one of the tenma-kun
rings of the Mandarin but this movie at
least doesn't specify
so Tony melts down the Palladium from
his rackets to construct the mini arc
reactor from a box of scraps and then
heat in the instant hammer together his
mark-1 armor marble later used this
exact hammer sound effect to play after
the credits of Avengers in game so the
Iron Man movies composer was Ramin
Djawadi
future composer a game of thrones in
west world Jawad ii sinks the hammer
strikes here with the scores machine
like rhythm tony's transformation in the
cave reflects Plato's allegory of the
cave Plato's idea is that humanity is
chained to a cave wall able only to see
shadows of reality but only by
unchaining oneself and escaping amid
lights can we see true enlightenment
Tony breaks his chains in the cave and
emerges enlightened and transformed when
the guards check in on them the first
guy to get hit is a cameo by Tom Morello
from Rage Against the Machine Solon
either as Tony escapes Raza fires a
projectile that Tony dodges and then
Tony responds by firing right back at
him
everybody Danny on discord pointed out
that this is the same move Tony uses on
the tank later and by the way so you all
know a few days before each of these
infinity saga rewatch videos come out
you can watch along with us live on
discord by becoming a patron of new rock
stars at patreon.com slash new rock
stars
so Tony escapes in somehow walks away
from the same kind of crash that nearly
kills rody in civil war and when he gets
back they stop at Burger King now this
was actually based on Downey's real life
he said in an interview that in 2003 he
was in his car with a ton of drugs and
his burger King burger was so gross that
him made him rethink his whole life and
he dumped his drugs in the ocean soon
thanks Burger King for helping me get
some whales addicted to heroin fun
detail here Tony tells OB that he only
has one burger left and then after
eating that burger
he later pulls out another burger to eat
her in the press conference pepper meets
agent coulson of the strategic homeland
intervention enforcement and logistics
division later foolish together a shield
in the comics shield originally stood
for supreme headquarters international
espionage line for sment division and 91
it was revised to strategic hazard
intervention espionage logistics
Directorate
this movie gives a throwback to that
history with the sighting of the yellow
in black logo on shield headquarters so
Tony calls off weapon manufacturing Obie
drops a reference to his comic villain
moniker where weapons manufacturer
Robbie I didn't want a body count to be
elsewhere ironmongers we make weapons
and a pepper plays operation on Tony
this effect was created with a
prosthetic chest projected out at an
angle with Robert Downey jr. hiding
underneath it with a bright light
shining to hide the edges of the fake
chest
they used the same trick in Star Trek
first contact but pepper ends up saving
Tony's old arc reactor this goes on to
become a symbol of Tony's rediscovered
soul he begins the film metaphorically
heartless and caring only for metal
they've transforms into a man with a
literal heart of metal carrying only for
human lives I just finally know what I
have to do I know in my heart that it's
right look folks I'm obsessed with
finding the answers to these questions
because I do not like to be surprised
surprised this I hate them the worst
surprise is a hidden B that pops up on
my bank statement well but what well
banking fees are a thing of the past
with current thanks to current for
sponsoring this video
current is a mobile bank account that
comes with a Visa debit card that has no
minimum balance no overdrafts and no
hidden fees see black premium card gets
you paid up to two days faster when you
move your direct deposit to current so
if you normally get paid on Fridays that
means with current your paycheck hits on
a Wednesday
current gives you a bank account in a
real debit card without all the fees and
requirements of old banks or sketchy
prepaid car
you can connect your current card to
cash app or venmo get cash back at the
register and deposit checks into your
account using your camera the premium
account has perks like instantly
refunding the holds that gas stations
put on your car to the pump the app
notifies you when you spend
automatically helps you put away money
with the savings pods
it has 24/7 support through live chat
plus current even has bank accounts for
teens if you're under 18 grreat works
with Apple pay and Google pay on your
phone and it's available in the US it
only takes two minutes to sign up and
your current card will be shipped to you
for free download current now at the
link in the description
Stanly originally based Tony Stark on
eccentric billionaire and daredevil
aviator Howard Hughes actually the
filmmaker shot Tony's workshop on the
soundstage at the former Howard Hughes
airport where Hughes built his Spruce
Goose plane
Tony flight tests the mark - Jarvis
tells him about the altitude record of
the sr-71 blackbird this is the jet that
inspired the x-jet blackbird used by the
x-men producer Kevin Feige previously
worked on the x-men film Tony freezes
over and this lesson ends up being
crucial in Tony's defeat of Obie later
which is foreshadowed by his crash
landing through the piano that Obie
played his envious Salieri song Tony
refines the suit into the mark three
armor with gold titanium alloy
reflecting the golden Avenger armor that
Iron Man war in the early comics but
Tony mixes it with hot rod read from his
roadster but there's another inspiration
here where Tony Stark's third annual
benefit for the firefighters family
fight it's a firefighter benefits where
Tony gets his first hero mission to go
mirror Tony sees himself as a
firefighter first responder who swoops
in hot spots to rescue innocents this
color red is also his way of expressing
that purpose at the benefit Tony passes
Stanley mistaken him to be Hugh Hefner
now Lee is not playing Hugh Hefner he's
credited as himself and in an alternate
version in the scene tony realizes his
mistake and stan responds that's okay I
get this all the time and Tony runs back
into Christine Curie Christie
Tony's making a Stephen King reference
Carrie and Christine are both famous
student King titles
she tells Tony about the refugee crisis
and goal mera which grabs Tony's
attention because it was Vincent's
hometown from small-time Costco Mita
this amazing gold mirror sequence has
awesome sound design very limited words
at least do a cacophony of screams but
Tony silence is it like an orchestra
conductor silence that makes Tony's one
line in the scene land perfectly he's
all yours
Tony ends up in a dogfight with f-22
Raptors one of the CA OC analysts is
Joshua harto he also played Coleman race
in the Dark Knight and notice how the
command addresses the pilots I've got
the bogey in my one what is it
and what did Tony say was the name of
the person Rudy once hooked up with that
lovely lady what was his name was it -
these sound like clues dropped by the
film setting up the villain of the
sequel Ivan Vanko whiplash and I just
got a shout out the amazing way this guy
refuses to punctuate his two sentences
that thing just took out an f-22 inside
a legal no-fly zone whiplash - if you
have a clear shot take it
yeah Obie's sue egg and covered lounge
notice the chessboard in the comics
Obadiah Stane creates a group called the
chessmen and Obi steals Raza scavenge
mark-1 armor kills his group meanwhile
in Tony's lab you can see a version of
caps shield being engineered on one of
the tables now obviously this isn't the
shield but with Tony's dad being such a
fan of cap over the years you can
imagine his son always wanting to build
a recreation of that shield pepper goes
into Tony's office to find files proving
Obie's illegal arms dealings if you look
closely at one of those files that says
the name Lebowski Jeff Bridges character
from The Big Lebowski
boom Tony also shouts out an in-game and
our man Lebowski keeps a chill with an
employee Tony Stark the box of scraps
this poor dude is William Ginter Reba
played by Peter Billingsley producer and
longtime collaborator of Jon Favreau who
as a kid played Ralphie and A Christmas
Story this character makes one of the
best ever returns eleven years later in
spider-man far from home applying his
engineering skills to Mysterio's drone
projection tech be not spat in this
guy's face Peter Parker could have just
had a normal neuro trip
oby paralyzes Tony there's so many
applications for clothing short-term
paralysis honey will actually apply this
tactic in a major battle later in his
life using mantis to put Thanos and
short-term paralysis so that they can
try like Obie did here to steal the
crown jewel weapon to eventually use
that weapon back against the previous
wielder and with the help of dummy tony
reaches peppers encased original arc
reactor making this the second time
peppers saved his life is
all to this operation and Tony's task in
the final act is to confront Obi who is
using his original mark-1 design against
him Tony has to defeat his past self the
hermit crabs shell he built in the cave
when walkers perhaps and outgrew so to
fully transform Tony must vanquish his
old self and to underline this
transformation Tony now launches out of
the same hole that he crash-landed
through earlier it mirrors his emergence
from death in the tomb to open air in
act 1 and this final watch must take him
past the ruins of the piano the boughs
of obese Salieri NB as Tony faces off to
face the enemy s pepper and Coulson's
search for Obie Favreau cranks of the
horror by hiding the monster behind
these chains
[Music]
yeah they use the same creepy chains
effect to hide the xenomorph and alien
as brent looks with a cat Jonesy tawny
and obese fight smashes into a truck
with a logo for rocks on the Marvel
energy conglomerate that is shown up in
the background of a bunch of places if
you look closely Roxanna is also on the
building behind them Tony it's a
defeating OB by applying the lessons we
saw him learn throughout the film
healers OB into high altitude causing
him to I see Brian's OB with flares like
he did to the f-22s he dismantles Obi's
armor as he did to his own Jericho
missiles in the cave and most
importantly he trusts pepper he stalks
pepper through a repeat of their
operation exercise earlier that was just
rehearsal now they have to save Tony's
life with an arc reactor on a giant
scale and now this final operation
defeats OB with these same power that
powers Tony's heart hurt power basically
Tony to find a way to make a lamest
Planeteer actually effective guys a
genius before his press conference Tony
reads a newspaper with a grainy photo
iron man through a barrier damn this
looks a lot like the leaked set photos
taken from Iron Man a year before the
movie came out it's so very cool the
movie to take back ownership of that and
Tony reveals himself to the world truth
is I am Iron Man really watching it it
makes the way endgame repurpose the line
even better according to Kevin Feige
Downey ad-lib to the line and a positive
reaction inspired them to move forward
in the MCU without secret identities
like Thor doesn't even bother with his
comics Donald Blake alter-ego even
Spiderman is now out at as Peter Parker
Tony's swagger his empathy is leading
with the heart has been the formula that
has made every MCU film the success that
it is put onto the actual reason people
watch these the post-credits scene you
think you're the only superhero in the
world mr. stark you become part of a
bigger universe you just don't know
who the hell are you Nick Fury director
of shield I'm here to talk to you about
the Avenger initiative
Feige revealed later than an alternate
take included direct references to
spider-man the x-men in the hall demo
accidents radioactive bug bites and
assorted mutants weren't enough I have
to deal with a spoiled brat doesn't play
well with others
and wants to keep all his toys to
himself at the time Marvel Studios
didn't have full ownership over any of
these popular titles they had a partner
with Universal to make the Incredible
Hulk which will be the next movie owner
infinity saga re-watch but all of these
years later Fighting's shooting the moon
paid off his success has given him
greater narrative control of her
spider-man in the Hulk and after the
buyout of Fox the reveal of the MCU
mutants is on the way
reminder that you can follow along with
our infinity Sakura watches on discord
by becoming a patron at patreon.com
slash new rock stars her next watch will
be the Incredible Hulk
aka the film that launched Thunderbolt
Ross on his destiny they become the
reinhold probably comment down below
follow me at EA vas follow new rock
stars and subscribed into rock stars on
YouTube for your daily dose as a
distraction
thanks for watching
[Music]